you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now that is
exactly right Junior weather buddy John
Legend qualified all right yeah the next
round of storms is pounding Pacific
Northwest so here's a great view from on
top of the Rio this is where most of the
country and a lot of people around the
world think everybody in Las Vegas lives
but obviously we know we have our own
Community here 62 degrees the official
reading on a reed International what's
happening where you are well with the
sort of blanket of cloud cover really
not much change at all between 59 and 61
all over the valley we'll obviously get
some breaks in the clouds but then we'll
have bigger waves of cloud cover coming
in over the next day or so and we'll
show you exactly where that's coming
from meanwhile to Nevada and Beyond not
very often that Laughlin knocking on the
door of 70 is warmer than Death Valley
over the Huffman prompt good afternoon
with your 55 low 40's for Cedar City
much better chances for snow perhaps an
additional foot or more at the higher
elevations over the next 24 to 48 hours
and then again potentially on the last
day of 2022 so here we are going for 64.
today we're 62 right now low this
morning 44. both of those numbers not
quite 10 degrees above or below normal
there's a record high of 73. so for your
family and friends across the country
still cleaning up from that mess in
Buffalo as we just saw there are more
snow showers moving across but nothing
like the bomb cyclone and here is that
next round again mostly rain but some of
it is in the form of snow mixed with ice
and rain all of that moving onshore for
us it's mostly going to be wind there'll
be slight chances for rain tomorrow
night and Wednesday but here in Las
Vegas we're talking about little or no
accumulation and there is another round
of cold going on as we speak but again
nothing like what those minus 20 degree
temperatures or wind chills at minus 40
single digits the actual temperature in
Bismarck Minneapolis at 12. Chicago's at
21. here is your most accurate eight day
forecast we're talking about winds
that's going to be the big story with
some clouds and slight chances for a
gusts of 30 miles an hour up to 66 then
down to 60 mid 50s for Thursday chances
for rain go away only to come back again
on the last day of 2022. John this is a
situation we're gonna have to watch for
those fireworks along the strip Saturday
night hopefully it doesn't put a damper
on bringing in 2023. thank you Nate